tredici anni fa ho fondato la scuola di
media design dell'adi questa accademia
milanese e mi sono trovato a fondare la
scuola è creare una nuova classe di
laurea del mio la propria codificarla si
lavorava sulle nuove tecnologie
era qualcosa che non esisteva
contemporaneamente ho messo in piedi il
dottorato di ricerca che era un piace di
inglese mi sono trovato nella
eccezionale posizione di essere
direttore del pd e studente lo stesso
tempo utilizzando come strumento o
dispositivo di ricerca la stessa
fondazione della scuola quindi una
veramente un triplo salto mortale con
avvitamento che però rappresenta molto
bene quello che sta succedendo che è
successo in questo tipo di istituzione
che potremmo definire come soft accade
di tutto c'è uno scenario
un'accelerazione estetica la scienza da
sperimentare diventa simulativa accelera
la sua capacità innovativa oltre alla
capacità del corpo sociale cosa vuoi
dire vuol dire che noi tutto quello che
parliamo che pensiamo e sempre vecchio
roma l'innovazione è accelerata issima è
spinta oltre la capacità che abbiamo di
condividere le informazioni concetti già
ormai codificati vent'anni fa come
monster media ovvero i media umidi mi
miglia ibridi tra tecnologia e strutture
viventi non sono ancora entrate nel
lessico comune
poi c'è la globalizzazione dei mercati
le merci diventano un prodotto vico e
cambiano le forme d'uso
e poi c'è la fine dei sistemi normativi
unici ovvero io mi trovavo ad avere a
che fare con studenti cinesi che non
hanno la minima idea di chi sono i
fondatori della nostra scuola e quindi i
cardini del nostro sapere nello scenario
è uno scenario della complessità che le
professioni tradizionali sembra non
essere più in grado di gestire e di
affrontare perché i media digitali che
sono quelli che hanno creato anche
queste sono il prodotto di questa
scienza ma sono anche quelli che sono
gli attori di questo nuovo
dinamico scenario ormai hanno mischiato
la produzione il marketing la ricerca la
comunicazione creando una mancanza cioè
abbattendo la separazione che c'è tra
prodotto comunicazione catalogazione e
archiviazione di questo stesso prodotto
si sente da parte dell'industria il
bisogno di una nuova poetica a
richiedere una nuova forma e descrizione
propria attenzione descrizione non è
solo mera vendita del prodotto il
prodotto stesso che ormai diventa il
materiale e che si racconta attraverso
se stesso io avevo a milano gravame
avevamo degli industriali che ci
chiedevano come fare a a entrare in
questa fase e poi abbiamo l'università
che include anche l'accademia che nel
processo di bologna cosa si è fatto se
standardizzato il processo si è creata
una uno scambio di crediti che sono
uguali in tutti i vari paesi però questa
cosa che è un grosso paradosso il
paradosso dell'omologazione difatti oggi
si parla di audit universiti cioè per
poter giudicare tutti allo stesso modo
si sono create di parametri universali
ma se noi abbiamo visto grande
cambiamento
questa dimensione così complessa come
può funzionare un audit university
infatti non è funzionale lo sviluppo non
riesce a dare una vera e propria
risposta perché abbiamo avuto una
singolarità la singolarità è stato
l'avvento dei sistemi aperti ovvero del
software aperto il solito aperto implica
uno sforzo collettivo implica quella che
derrick de kerckhove ha definito suo
nome con un neologismo estremamente
appropiato li pertinenza cioè il fatto
che noi siamo il prodotto delle nostre
menti e delle macchine che stiamo usando
che ormai le macchine non sono più
macchine che muovono che fanno forza ma
sono macchine che implicano il nostro
pensiero è che portano avanti il nostro
fare
e immaginate linux quando uscì linux
sembrava un qualcosa di non utile
non invece è il software libero che ha
rivoluzionato completamente immaginate
arduino io mi ricordo il giorno in cui
massimo banzi venne da me in questa
accademia e mi disse io ho fatto un
attuatore e io disse cos'è un attuatore
è un qualcosa che fa cadere cose
ed allora abbiamo iniziato ha iniziato
insegnarvi è stato a lavorare insieme
però questo ha portato cosa anche un
modello educativo aperto quest'apertura
questo modo di collaborare ha creato
questa grande comunità glocale di
docenti che si muovono a livello
internazionale e che sono impediti dalla
struttura classica dell'università
mentre io cosa ho potuto fare ho potuto
chiamare tutte queste persone ho potuto
creare un nodo all'interno di un network
che era globalizzato e questa è stata
una delle chiavi della della del
successo inoltre glocale una parola
molto importante non esiste globalità
non esiste località esiste la glocalità
è negato una conoscenza ibrida laddove
non si può cogliere l'insieme del sapere
se non si coglie tanti saperi differenti
quindi le discipline hanno iniziato a
erodersi hanno iniziato a entrare in
contrasto nato l'altro hanno iniziato a
cercare delle forme sincretica di
interrelazione una con l'altra
sincretica non è sintesi secret ed a
udire ognuna mantiene la propria
identità ma tutte si mischiano tutte
iniziano a lavorare insieme e quindi è
nata quello il modello che abbiamo fatto
che a questa educazione cibernetica
aperta ci permette una par un po pesante
ma effettivamente quello che rende
l'idea
in tutte queste accademie hanno una
perenne ricerca per quello che dicevo
prima abbiamo un accelerazione così
forte dell'innovazione che non si può
che lavorare in una perenne stato di
ricerca quindi diciamo il modello del
dottorato di ricerca del pg di classico
viene riportato addirittura dentro il
livello del gay del triennio poi l'arte
si configura è qui che già sta la
centralità delle accademie belle arti
come unica disciplina in grado di agire
fuori dall estetiche cioè di agire in
maniera completamente a disciplinare
l'accademia di vento nome o stato
culturale ovvero diventa e a questa
regola
innovativa quando la società e
conservatrice e conservatrice quando la
società innovativa proprio perché
funziona come oh me oh stato continua a
darti una risposta una controrisposta in
funzione di quello che sta avvenendo e
poi soprattutto un'altra
interessantissima questione non c'è più
il direttore didattico non c'è più il
direttore che poi sarei stato io però è
il processo che controlla tutto
attenzione è lo stesso modello del pgt
del dottorato di ricerca c'è qualcuno
che controlla l'oggettività della
ricerca quale che sia ma non controlla
la direzione alla direzionalità
questo perché oggi abbiamo bisogno del
pensiero laterale pensiero laterale che
ha ricercato e volutamente finanziato
oggi anche dalla comunità europea con il
processo start science technology and
art che poi stars sta anche per start up
perché si pensa che solo attraverso
questa ibridazione dei saperi
questo nuovo approccio che in the mette
l'arte come elemento che muove prima di
quello che poi sarà la
industrializzazione l'ingegnerizzazione
che muove l'idea si possa arrivare a
rimanere sincronizzati con questa grande
innovazione che abbiamo oggi noi abbiamo
codificato poi questa è accademia che di
fatto l'accademia d'arte ma che lavora
sull'innovazione su un pensiero del
contemporaneo attraverso tre assi
disciplinari la narratologia cioè lo
storytelling perché qualsiasi prodotto
oggi è una forma di narrazione qualsiasi
tecnica viene compresa solo se narrata
poi una disciplina centrale che è la
filosofia della tecnica la filosofia
assurdamente è viva nell'accademia di
belle arti questo interessantissimo
tutti i giovani più grandi filosofi
adesso stanno lavorando nella catena
belle arti berna stiegler uno più
importanti filosofi della tecnica
attuale e il direttore dei suns compito
di parigi il pit slot lei che era il
direttore della zkm di karlsruhe sono
accademie di belle arti e io avevo un
sacco di giovani molto bravi che adesso
sono all'estero lavorare sulla filosofia
della tecnica è semplice si interrogano
gli effetti della testa e la tecnica su
di noi cosa ha fatto l'artista è colui
che ha sempre esplorato con la tecnica
così come giorgione dipingeva queste
luci questi territori con la tecnica
dell'epoca e si poneva la domanda di
come rappresentare il territorio e la
luce con i colori ad olio oggi l'artista
si pone l'idea di come rappresentare la
realtà attraverso gli strumenti
dispositivi che abbiamo cioè i media
elettronici e poi le arti visive e
torniamo a quello che dicevo prima le
arti visive sono lo strumento della
ricerca la ricerca si fa diventando
artisti ponendosi oltre il limite oltre
il limite delle categorie ormai
riconosciute e codificate perché quello
che codificato è già vecchio
recentemente questo ci tengo a citarlo
nicholas negroponte ha detto che non
abbiamo più bisogno di scuole di
business administration abbiamo bisogno
di art school perché ormai felice sità
operative sono assolti
dall'automatizzazione ciò di cui si
avverte il bisogno e la capacità di
produrre nuovi sistemi multimediali e
molte tecnologici questa è una svolta
epocale stato un annuncio molto
importante da totale del fondatore del
medialab dell'emmeti l'accademia di
belle arti quindi secondi si configura
come un dispositivo di alta formazione
molto più vicino all'impresa che
l'università perché produce
continuamente un territorio aperto che
si configura come pratica artistica come
dispositivi conoscenza più adatto a un
contemporaneo e l'esperienza della
creazione del prodotto è fondamentale
nella società di oggi in quanto
l'industria si trasforma i prodotti le
esperienze questo è che ho notato lo ha
avuto una pro una altissima penetrazione
nostri studenti nel mondo del lavoro
proprio per questo perché sapevano fare
delle esperienze concrete dai pori un
periodo in cui tutta la funzionalità
pura lancia le forme d'uso e vince
l'arte riapre significato essa è
premessa della scienza riapre
significati e quelli richiude la scienza
dà delle risposte a delle domande che
sono state e sono sempre state aperte
dall arte questa è un'altra cosa da
capire da vedere in questo rapporto che
è il rapporto tra arte scienza e
tecnologia
contemporaneamente siamo resi conto
grazie a questa grossa prestazione
mercato che stavamo creando un nuovo
lavoratore e lo stiamo codificando
adesso bisogna formare un interprete del
nuovo millennio un attore impertinente
della multi verità della multimedialità
scusate la figura che occupi posizioni
di responsabilità tanto nei processi
produttivi che nel mondo delle aziende
anche lì abbiamo visto che questi
giovani creati da peyo delle arte hanno
ruoli di responsabilità aziendale è una
figura che supererà quella che il chief
information officer si occuperà di
ricerca e sviluppo per queste visioni
che l'arte ci permette di dare e in
questo compito sarà chiamato a dare un
significato nuovo la sua creatività che
vi viene oggi capitale umano innovativo
di innesti di inestimabile valore e
questo era il messaggio che volevo dare
e che fu che su cui stiamo lavorando
grazie